en France une grossesse sur 4 est une
fausse couche et une femme sur 10 au
cours de sa vie vit une fausse couche la
fausse couche est un phénomène naturel
qui parfois peut être vécue
difficilement pour les femmes et pour
les couples et en fait il faut savoir
que les femmes et les couples qui ont
des difficultés à vivre l'épreuve de la
fausse couche on y représente des
symptômes de dépression d'angoisse si
l'accompagnement psychologique fait
défaut je suis ravie de porter cette
proposition loi au nom du MoDem au nom
de la politique sociétale une politique
familiale pour l'accompagnement des
femmes et des couples le fond de cette
proposition de loi est de proposer un
parcours fausse couche sur tous les
territoires de France et d'outre-mer en
lien avec les agences régionales de
santé afin de déployer un vrai réseau de
professionnels de les former et de
permettre aux personnes qui le
souhaitent aux femmes et aux couples
d'être vraiment accompagné
psychologiquement suite à une fausse
couche la femme vit au cours de sa vie
plusieurs plusieurs changements parfois
certaines épreuves la fausse couche en
est une donc l'accompagnement
psychologique est important pour lui
permettre si elle le souhaite d'être
mieux accompagné et de mieux vivre cette
épreuve qui parfois peut aussi toucher
le couple c'est pour ça que la
composition va vise à l'accompagnement
psychologique des couples victimes de
fausse couche aussi on peut aussi
imaginer aujourd'hui quand par exemple
une femme vit une fausse couche elle
peut demander à un arrêt maladie le
gouvernement souhaite lever le jour de
carence c'est-à-dire que la femme pourra
prendre son arrêt maladie sans subir ce
jour de carence pour le 8 mars c'est un
aussi un bon un bon point pour ce qui
concerne l'évolution des droits des
femmes